aunque no estés de estudiante aquí en
canadá pero oriunda de méxico y como
estudiante y estudiante latinoamericana
además en este país ha tenido siempre un
interés particular por lo que es hallar
soluciones viables para el tratamiento
del agua y la energía porque nos cuenta
un poco sobre esto
claro
desde que llegué a canadá yo tenía la
idea de que iba a venir aquí iba a poder
aprender acerca de
cómo crear soluciones que podrían ayudar
en casa no yo yo nací y crecí en mexico
y crecí viendo no solamente a veces
mucha desigualdad social pero también
como la falta de acceso a servicios
básicos impactaba mucho la vida de la
gente entonces este estando aquí en la
universidad de toronto pude conocer a la
profesora y me billiton
y ella tiene su laboratorio que se llama
este water and energy research y
lamentos del laboratorio de este agua y
energía y sus proyectos básicamente se
basan en tratar de entender a las
comunidades para las cuales estás
haciendo un proyecto este vasco
bajo el foco de agua o energía no y
entonces dentro de su laboratorio
también hay otro estudiante mexicano que
está haciendo su posgrado y él estaba
trabajando con comunidades en la
periferia de ciudades mexicanas y estaba
tratando de comprender cómo la falta de
acceso a agua o tecnologías de
saneamiento afectaba su vida
algo que se dio cuenta es que no
solamente es que a la gente que vive
generalmente en las periferias de la
ciudad es que les falta el agua sino que
no tienen sistemas de saneamiento
efectivos entonces tienen sistemas de
saneamiento en los que el agua de
desecho se queda estancada por días este
que ni siquiera se puede jalar el agua
bien entonces esto te trae una serie de
problemas que no vería a ser que en un
lugar como toronto probablemente no
entonces
y yo lo que quería poder hacer era pues
de éste
y poner mi tiempo en un proyecto que
siento que ayudaría a mi casa y que me
ayudaría a mejorar las vidas de aquellos
que están en méxico entonces no sé me
interesa mucho este tema de
infraestructura del agua y
particularmente el saneamiento y cómo
podría usar ingeniería para ayudarlos y
desde sus conocimientos de ingeniería
una de las investigaciones que usted ha
tomado está tomando parte es en el uso
de energía solar para purificar el agua
claro sí sí sí entonces ese es otro
proyecto en el que también trabajamos en
el laboratorio y esto se basa en crear
sistemas de osmosis reversa entonces
básicamente son sistemas de filtración
de agua en la que tienes unas este
membranas de filtración y pasas a agua
con este presión es muy muy altas y
entonces filtradas este cualquier tipo
de contaminantes este la idea es hacer
estos sistemas para que puedan ser
utilizados en comunidades remotas
entonces cómo logras eso bueno pues
necesitas
darles energía a través de stern
sistemas robustos como lo pueden ser
paneles solares entonces nosotros nos
estamos dedicando a diseñar un sistema
que pudiera darle agua potable a una
comunidad escolar en bangladesh en
particular entonces la diseñamos para
que también estuviera esté unida a un
sistema de desinfección en v
entonces usando rayos ultravioletas este
con l de esto puedes también eliminar
cualquier microorganismo microorganismo
que haya pasado las membranas de
filtración entonces la idea de esto es
simplemente crear un sistema bastante
robusto para que estudiantes en esta
comunidad puedan tener acceso a agua y
no tengan que caminar cientos de
kilómetros para poder accesar a agua
entonces esa es en realidad es el
proyecto también y en ese sentido una de
las cosas que se ha señalado a diversas
disciplinas no solamente genera
es que muchas veces están separadas
distantes de lo que es por un lado las
necesidades de la gente pero por el otro
lado las costumbres de los lugares a los
cuales esos proyectos pretenden ser
destinados en el caso de los mensajes de
las investigaciones en las que usted
participa cómo se compatibiliza en esas
dos cuestiones su interés en ingeniería
por un lado el aporte de la ingeniería y
de la tecnología al progreso de las
personas y las costumbres la cultura y
uruguay del lugar en el cual esos
proyectos van a ser aplicados pero ese
es un punto muy interesante y de hecho
algo que realmente quiero que conforme
me muevo en mi carrera que realmente
esté sembrado en su centro no y es el
tomar en cuenta para quién estás
diseñando algo no y tenemos un término
en ingeniería que le llamamos el diseñar
para este justicia social entonces lo
que eso
lo que hizo este tome en cuenta es
tienes que conocer a las comunidades no
necesariamente algo que funciona en lo
que gente podrá llamar no un país
primermundista este va a funcionar en
todas las comunidades del mundo no se
van a adaptar a lo que es su realidad
entonces hay distintas maneras para
hacer esto pero una es ir platicar con
la gente leer este que han hecho otras
personas que ha funcionado y porque no
ha funcionado y eso es algo muy
importante no siento que en el mundo de
ingeniería o inclusive la academia
muchas veces los errores o los fallos no
sé no se comunican no nos dicen saben
que implementamos este proyecto en este
no sé en méxico y no funciona pero nadie
dice porque no funcionó y eso es para mí
un gran error es importante considerar
cuáles son los éxitos y cuáles fueron
los errores para que entonces tú puedes
realmente estudiar que se puede adaptar
o no a la cultura de un lugar no
entonces por ejemplo en el caso de el
proyecto éste
con unidades pero urbanas en méxico
parte del miro lo que yo quería hacer
entender no solamente el contexto
geográfico de estas personas pero si nos
su contexto social entonces que irán los
factores que los llevado llevaron a no
poder tener acceso a sistemas de
saneamiento efectivos no entonces a
través de recopilar información de esta
institución es como el inegi el inegi en
méxico es una institución que recopila
muchísimos datos de toda la población
mexicana esté cada creo que es cinco
años tienen censos este nacionales iván
como cuadra por cuadra no entrevistando
a casa por casa y luego a esto le unir
este datos que tiene la organización
este sin fines de lucro techo por mi
país que es también no para ambas varios
países de latinoamérica este lo que eso
me permitió ver como estaba analizando
todo
es que la gente que vive en estas
comunidades forma parte de la economía
informal de méxico y como me di cuenta
de esto bueno porque la mayoría de ellos
no tenían acceso a sistemas de salud
este sistema de salud a seguros entonces
que te dice esto pues si esta gente no
es parte de estas instituciones formales
del país entonces no va a tener acceso a
la mayoría de los servicios básicos que
alguien estándar debería tenerlo
entonces digo esto es un paso muy
pequeño pero siento que es algo
importante cuando estás diseñando
cualquier tipo de cosas tienes que
ponerte en los pies de la comunidad y
realmente entender su percepción del
mundo para saber qué es lo que les va a
funcionar a ellos
muchas veces hemos visto ideas que los
papeles son brillantes pero que después
llevadas a la práctica no prenden en la
gente cómo sería
sencillos adriana y comas que surgió el
interés en la ingeniería y leído por ahí
que desde muy pequeña soñaba con ser
científica no sé si esto será música
bueno desde que yo tenía 12 años me hice
a la edad de que quería ser ingeniera y
para llamarme loca pero todo sucedió
porque
mi papá mi hermano es varias de las
figuras importantes en mi familia han
sido ingenieros entonces creo que desde
muy chiquita se me sembró la semilla de
decir oh guau ingeniería suena muy padre
pero lo que lo comento fue este me
acuerdo que uno de los amigos más
cercanos de la familia llegó un día con
una revista de national geographic a mi
casa y me dijo como guau
adriana mira este está angustiando en
mosquitos para este tratar de curar este
malaria no y yo como que y entonces me
puse a buscar que era esta ingeniera
genética no y ahí en mi mente de 12 años
ya me veía ganando el proyecto dijo por
qué existe este pero creo que algo que
es muy parte de mi naturaleza es que me
agarró estas ideas y empiezo a decir
como ok y cómo puedo usar esto no hoy y
siempre me gustó comprender al mundo
entender cómo funcionaban las cosas
pero algo que me impulso mucho más es le
empecé a dar cuenta que ingeniería es un
muy buen camino para realmente crear
soluciones no solamente quedarte sentado
criticando a cosas sino realmente poder
tener un rol activo en como quieres
que cambien las situaciones con las que
no estás de acuerdo entonces creo que
ese fue lo que me impulsó a conseguir el
camino de ingenierías y una de esas
situaciones con las que te involucras en
su proceso de cambio es en el tema de la
inserción de la mujer en ciertas ramas
del conocimiento y en ciertas
actividades laborales como pueden ser en
el punto del caso académico en todo caso
de ingeniería las matemáticas lo que se
llaman las ciencias duras donde no se
suele ver mucha presencia aún en
nuestros días aunque parezca mentira
decirlo no hay muchas mujeres presentes
si tú estás bregando por que esto cambie
si dentro de la universidad de toronto
soy parte de un grupo estudiantil se
llama high school es este y lo que
tratamos de les tratamos de hacer
eventos para estudiantes de secundaria y
lo que le llaman aquí el virus q también
para introducirlos a ingeniería y aunque
esto no está solamente enfocado en traer
mujeres la mayor parte del equipo somos
mujeres en este momento no entonces y
algo con las que todos razonamos es
queremos decirle a aquellas que piensan
o les han dicho que no pueden que si
pueden no decirles esto es lo que
ingeniería es lo que lo que te puede
abrir las puertas y no
o cualquier carrera en ciencias y no es
que no pueda perseguir carrera en
humanidades o en las artes vallado
siento que hay una complejidad inmensa
en cualquier carrera de profesión que tú
decidas tener pero creo que hay un gran
estigma este con niñas con mujeres en
las que se les dice que no son capaces o
están intimidados decir bueno es que
nada más son este hombres los que están
ahí no sé cómo me vayan a tratar
creo que a través de grupos
estudiantiles como este puedes traer sus
experiencias a niños más jóvenes y
decirles mira
mira lo que puedes lograr puedes venir
aquí no vas a estar sola eso es lo más
importante siempre va a haber gente que
te esté apoyando esta gente que te guíe
en el camino cuando las cosas se ponen
difíciles y bueno eso me parece algo muy
importante nomás cuando recuerdo como en
mi propia secundaria este que
no muchos niños están pensando cómo
estudiar algo de ciencias no eran como
hay matemáticas no no no qué cosa tan
horrible este pero vallarán tiene algo
muy muy bello y creo que cuando ves
gente con la que te puedas relacionar
que ha tomado ese camino es más fácil
como que darte tu empujoncito decir cómo
van a ver si ellos pudieron yo también
puedo entonces no sé es algo importante
para mí las carreras tecnológicas siguen
siendo un ámbito poco visitado por las
mujeres aún hoy en día y para aquellas
niñas o jóvenes que tanto tal vez en
méxico como en otros países de américa
latina y de habla hispana en general
vean tu caso que les dirías por qué
saltar de mexico en tu caso a canadá
porque irse desde otro lugar y venir a
estudiar aquí que cuál es la ventaja que
es lo que en este caso a ti la
universidad de toronto te agrega
cuáles son las puertas que te ha abierto
esta universidad
yo
creo que lo que me las puertas que me ha
abierto aquí es
simplemente es el panorama que te da
todo no conoces a gente de todos los
rincones del mundo
pero también de todo tipo de contextos
tanto culturales religiosos estrés y
poder tener poder estar expuesta a todo
eso como milán
me da confianza decir sabes que gente en
méxico también puede también puede
crecer tanto no y no es decir que o sea
que no puedes estudiar ciencia
ingeniería en méxico vaya universidades
como la unam el tec buenísimas pero creo
que también
el poder el hacer el salto digamos acá
hace canadá te abre mucho la perspectiva
de cómo se tratan ciertos problemas en
otros países de cómo el acceso a
educación se ve en distintos países y
cómo lo puedes mejorar en casa no y qué
programas han facilitado que la gente se
mueva de punto a punto ve acá y creo que
eso es algo que me gustaría a mí traer
de regreso a méxico me gustaría poder
traer esta perspectiva internacional
esta perspectiva de diversidad e
inclusión que siento que está muy como
en las raíces de la universidad de
toronto y muy en las raíces de
ingeniería en la universidad de toronto
algo que realmente me gustaría traer de
regreso a casa este que es algo que no
necesariamente puedes conseguir ahí
adriana díaz lozano patiño muchas
gracias por su entrevista con radio que
nos da internacional gracias